Rob here with the gamespot news update
it looks like the Star Wars Battlefront
beta doesn't quite run at 1080p on the
PlayStation 4 and Xbox one a new
technical analysis of the ongoing Star
Wars Battlefront beta reveals that the
playstation 4 edition runs at 900p while
the Xbox one edition is 720p digital
foundry today posted its breakdown of
the Xbox one version specifically which
outlines the game performance on
Microsoft's console in regards to the
Xbox one version digital foundry said
from an image quality perspective the
compromises are just as you would expect
we see more aliased edges and a higher
level of shimmering on find distant
detail particularly on tattooing flag
lines visual boundary goes on to say
that texture and shadow quality are
identical between both consoles while
the same is true for their use of
tessellated geometry across the max both
games also experience a similar level of
pop in both consoles consistently head
around 60 frames per second but the xbox
one version did drop to 50 during some
of the more intensive scenes by the look
of it it sounds like the ps4 isn't
slightly better shape the pc version
will vary depending on your setup the
Battlefront beta open to public
yesterday will continue throughout the
weekend full game will hit shelves on
november seventeenth are you having fun
with battlefront you really care about
all these tech specs does Luke Skywalker
really need a green lightsaber on Hoth
for all of your battlefront news you've
got a gamespot com
you